bruno daroux bonjour poutine veut forcer
les européens à payer en roubles euros
fusent la france et l'allemagne se
prépare même à un arrêt des importations
de gaz oui c'est un peu d'une certaine
manière la réponse du berger à la
bergère en la russie donc lourdement
frappée par les sanctions occidentales
sur son économie est bien riposte en
essayant de faire des dégâts sur
l'économie européenne
ainsi vladimir poutine dit que tout ça
va c'est la faute des occidentaux en
fait qui ont commencé les sanctions que
ces sanctions dyer avait été préparée de
très longue date avant même l'invasion
et que donc les européens avaient
l'intention d'affaiblir l'économie russe
toujours est-il qu'il sort sa contre
attaque aujourd'hui alors c'était déjà
dans l'air depuis quelques jours mais là
il dit qu' à partir de demain eh bien
les clients de les clients occidentaux
de la russie en termes de gaz devront
payer leur gaz en roubles donc avoir des
comptes en roubles sur gazprombank sinon
il n'y aura pas de livraisons de fait la
russie couperait le robinet pour
l'europe occidentale ce qui impacterait
lourdement certains pays européens au
premier rang desquels évidemment
l'allemagne dans une moindre mesure la
france il y à aussi l'italie et d'autres
pays d'europe du nord donc effectivement
c'est une menace très très importante de
parce qu'effectivement vous l'avez dit
les européens refusent de rentrer dans
ce hit ce système pourquoi parce que
s'ils commencent à payer en roubles et
bien ça va faire remonter leur groupe
qu'ils vont acheter du rouble et donc ça
va annuler en partie l'effet des
sanctions qu'ils ont décidées contre la
russie donc on est là dans ce bras de
fer énergétique les européens notamment
la france et l'allemagne qui disent
qu'ils se préparent à une coupure des
livraisons par la russie qui dénonce un
chantage de la part de moscou puisque ce
paiement en rouble devrait donc
s'effectuer à partir du 1er avril c'est
à dire demain en même temps côté
français allemands ont fait comprendre
qu'on reste un peu sceptique sur la
réalité de la mise en oeuvre de cette
menace mais on voit clairement
vladimir poutine près par les européens
à une guerre économique et prépare aussi
sa propre population à vivre en état
d'économies de guerre cette fois ci et
il veut d'ailleurs relancer certaines
constructions notamment la construction
d'avions russes les russes qui pourront
toujours vendre leur gaz et leur pétrole
plus vers l'est notamment à la chine et
à l'inde puisque sergei lavrov est en
déplacement dans ces deux pays oui c'est
ça c'est ça le projet en quelque sorte
alternatif de la russie c'est à dire
puisque les relations économiques avec
l'europe de l'ouest se tend de
considérablement notamment en termes de
livraisons de gaz qui rapporte il faut
le dire des recettes très importante à
l'état russe eh bien on va essayer de
livrer ce gaz est ce pétrole aussi à la
chine et à l'inde c'est déjà le cas mais
effectivement l'un des buts de la
tournée diplomatique de sergueï lavrov
hier à pékin aujourd'hui et demain en
inde il ya un but diplomatique bien sûr
c'est de renforcer l'unité de ces
nations contre le bloc occidental
il ya aussi un but économique
c'est-à-dire augmenter les contrats
augmenter les livraisons de gaz et de
pétrole à ces deux géants quand même qui
a eu deux font plus de 3 milliards
d'habitants pour essayer d'amoindrir le
coup corée pour l'économie russe le fait
de ne plus livrer du gaz à l'europe de
l'ouest affaire à suivre merci beaucoup
bruno